you know the U.S built the current
International order after World War II
but at that time our economy was half of
the world's economy so we were so strong
we could set the terms
um now other countries are getting
richer and we're living so far beyond
our means
isn't it inevitable that there's going
to be some change in the international
order that we created
the position we had at the end
of the second World War
was not sustainable
even with Good Financial qualities
because it was going to be some other
country
in a set of countries
was going to rise
but the position of leadership
of some kind
was theoretically sustainable
at the end of the second world war we
were predominant it was beyond
leadership
uh
I would describe leadership when your
capacitors
military militarily or economically
and internally
produce answers which other societies
can Orient themselves to their benefit
it's the second
quality we have that has been declining
in the United States
together with the financial situation
and partly for the reasons that they
give when
confidence in
leadership declines in about and when
they pointed reached
where the
purpose of your country become a
domestic issue and when you have a
significant segment of the population
that is questioning the basics
purposes then you lose the capacity for
sacrifice
and you you would see
commitment to taking a broad view in
which you willing to
sacrifice
to some extent in the present for the
sake of the future
and that is to me the challenge to
American leadership today the effective
conditions are changing around the world
and the internal conditions in America
about the nature of leadership
have become seriously under attack